c'est étonnant non
bonsoir madame bonsoir mademoiselle
bonsoir Monsieur et bien je suis content
qu'une fois de plus vous soyez fidèle à
notre rendez-vous mensuel de face à face
ce soir face à face débattra du problème
de l'armement atomique et pour cela j'ai
le plaisir d'accueillir à ma droite à ma
droite Monsieur Joseph marotini qui est
le ministre de
l'Armement et qui tentera donc de nous
convaincre de l'utilité d'un armement
nucléaire dans une nation civilisée
tandis kamago comme à gauche je me suis
Sébastien Ducharme qui est président du
mouvement écologiste de France édit en
fera bien évidemment de nous convaincre
du contraire après tirage au sort c'est
un monsieur Sébastien Ducharme que
revient le droit d'intervenir en premier
vous avez donc deux premières minutes
d'intervention c'est à vous monsieur
Ducharme
bien monsieur Ducharme je suis désolé de
vous interrompre mais vos deux minutes
sont écoulées et c'est maintenant à
Monsieur le Ministre d'intervenir
non je vous en prie on fait du chat
c'est
si vous le permettez j'aimerais
soumettre quelques statistiques à
monsieur duchard je vous en prie faites
[Musique]
quand j'ai compté monsieur le ministre
et c'est à vous maintenant de reprendre
pour la dernière fois la parole et
ensuite ce sera à vous de conclure
j'ai apporté ici quelques produits que
j'aimerais faire tester à Monsieur
[Musique]
un accessoire qui tenterait approuver
l'efficacité de la force de frappe
et bien il est temps maintenant de
rendre l'antenne merci Monsieur le
Ministre merci Monsieur Ducharme merci
Monsieur Ducharme bien sûr chacun de nos
invités n'aura certainement convaincu
que ce qui lui était déjà acquis mais la
conclusion de Monsieur le Ministre bien
que brève en fera certainement réfléchir
plus d'un
et bien maintenant il nous reste à vous
dire bonsoir madame bonsoir mademoiselle
bonsoir Monsieur et rendez-vous dans un
mois pour la suite de cette émission
[Musique]